hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm back with the fourth
installment of our semi daily Q&A and
the question today is if specificity is
very important for building strength for
mastering the motor skills of the
specific movements that you're using to
test strength why use exercise
variations in the first place so in the
context of powerlifting if you're trying
to get your squat bench deadlift up why
would you ever do anything other than
just the competition variants of squat
bench and deadlift you know why would
you do front squats close grip bench
deadlift with the opposite stance block
poles etc and it comes down to two basic
reasons the first has to do with motor
learning there's a theory in just
learning in general that a lot of how we
learn isn't just from repetition but is
from error identification and correction
and so as you practice a movement you
get really good with it and it's easy to
kind of go on autopilot it's it's easy
to to tune out a little bit as you're
doing it so you're you're a little bit
less engaged or just you get really
really strong and the weights for the
competition variant become very very
challenging and you're more just kind of
focused on getting the weight up than
the actual execution of the lift and
mastering it and so when you introduce
exercise variations there's their
movements that you're a little bit less
familiar with so errors and execution
are going to be much much more obvious
much much more noticeable so you get
more opportunities for identifying
errors and correcting them with very
similar movements that are then going to
transfer to the main lifts so say in the
case of the squat you know if you're a
low bar squatter in competition front
squat a high bar
squat Paula squat those are all still
training the general motor skill of the
squat but by introducing those
variations you're going to kind of throw
yourself into waters that are a little
bit less comfortable so you're going to
make more errors be able to identify
more errors and master that general
motor skill of squatting that you'll be
able to then transfer over to your low
bar squating competition you you see
this in a lot of motor learning research
in general as well if you want you can
just run a quick search for constant
versus varied to practice in almost any
motor skill the vast vast majority of
the time varied practice beats out
constant practice and and this is kind
of the theory behind it that if you're
doing the exact same thing all the time
you just don't have as many
opportunities to identify and correct
errors now if you're training with a
coach I think it is a lot easier to
maybe make your training a little bit
more vanilla and that be very successful
you see this with say borscht Eiko's
lifters they pretty much only stick to
squat and bench they do have some more
variation in their deadlift training but
if you have a coach watching you and you
know pointing out things that you can
improve with each rep even if you do
kind of have that natural inclination to
just sort of go on autopilot with
movements that you've done a lot that
you're very very comfortable with under
a coach's watchful eye that's going to
help with error identification and
correction you know giving you things to
watch out for on the next set next
workout etc so I don't I certainly don't
think that exercise variation is
necessary but I do think that that is
one of the biggest benefits for most
people including it in their program
it's just going to you know give you
something you're not quite as accustomed
to to help you better master the general
motor skills of squatting benching dead
lifting so that's number two or that's
number one number two is that just by
including some slight variation that's
probably going to help
reduce your risk of overuse injuries now
I'm not going to pretend like there's
research to support this but again in
general if you look at pretty much any
other sport in existence the the more
you're doing the exact same thing over
and over and over the higher your risk
of overuse injuries is so for example
just by analogy
runners tend to have a much much higher
injury risk than triathletes do because
all they're doing for the most part is
running and so a lot of running coaches
recommend cross-training to their
runners when they're not in competitive
season just to cut down on that risk of
overuse injury whereas you know
triathletes they're biking swimming
running all the time so they're they do
have a little bit more variety there so
they tend to have lower rates of overuse
injury just for myself and in people
I've coached in just observing athletes
in the gym I do I do tend to find that
people who do have a little bit more
variety in their training their their
results may not be quite as good in the
short term because they aren't getting
that highly highly specific practice and
that that would especially be true for
may be newer lifters or intermediate
lifters but I do find that they end up
not having to take as much time off with
overuse injuries whereas people who use
really high volumes it's just a very
small array of exercises a lot of them
do tend to struggle more with overuse
injuries that's just an observation I've
made so to answer this question summing
up the video again two biggest benefits
of including some more variation is one
the general motor learning benefits of
giving you more opportunities more
abilities to identify and correct errors
and technique that may not be quite as
obvious if you're just sticking with a
smaller set of movements and the other
is that I do think it's going to be
beneficial for helping you reduce your
risk of overuse injuries so you can stay
in the gym and keep training hard okay
so that is the video if you liked it
please like and subscribe and if you
have questions you want answered ask
them in the comments below and if I like
your question I will pick it and answer
it in our video tomorrow alright guys
until next time